today we're checking out the mini 2 by
dji this is the second version of this
mini drone and i love this so much
because it is only 249 grams which makes
it one of the smallest and lightest
drones that dj has in their current
lineup here's two different versions
that you can get you can get just the
drone and then the fly more combo which
comes with the controller extra
batteries and a case this is one of my
favorite drones by dji even though this
is geared towards more of the beginner
drone flyers
even though i would consider myself a
little more advanced i love this because
it's so small so compact the biggest
difference between the mini and the mini
2 is this one will now shoot in 4k
i will be doing a flight demo later in
this video but first we have to unbox it
i'm going to be unboxing the fly more
combo and this one is for my sister
jenna you can check out her channel i'll
put a link in the description she also
makes fun tech videos
and really fun vlogs as well so jenna
this one's for you
we are heading out on an adventure this
weekend because when there's a new drone
you gotta go somewhere outside of your
house because when i covered the mavic
air 2
it was still in the middle of the
pandemic i thought i would do a drone
test
in my house and i flew it into my
curtains and i
i gotta turn obstacle avoidance
[Music]
so we can slide free
[Applause]
we're not gonna do that anymore a lot of
these drones do have prop guards if you
do want to fly them in the house i
recommend
putting those on because they are there
for a reason if i would have had those
prop guards on my curtains would not
have a huge hole in them
oh hello
oh so this one comes in like a little
carrying case
this unboxing has turned into an
unbagging
i like this they have everything all
like nicely packed for me
i could have just took this already and
gone on my trip
look at these little propellers they've
got them in little individually wrapped
little baggies this looks like something
that you would eat like some candy like
a snack
but they're not controller i think this
is heavier than the drone
this is definitely heavier than the
drone
whoa this has a cool little seat belt
please use the propeller holder to
protect the propel this is actually
a really great idea so this is to hold
the propellers in place
and because this is so small i used to
just throw this into like my backpack or
something and then the propellers would
just kind of be like free-flowing
but this is really a great idea i'm glad
that they did this
battery compartment usb to charge sd
card slot
super small super super compact
like look at this it's so little see
what else we have in here
so here's everything that comes in the
fly more kit you have your drone the
drone propeller holder
you have this multi battery charger
which is
so much easier to take out than the last
version usb-c
cable charger the new controller this
was first released
in the mavic air 2 that came out a few
months ago at first i thought this
controller was a little bit too big but
now that i've been using it and flying
with the air 2 a lot i actually really
like it i like that this has joystick
compartments already so you can put
those there when you're not using it
but when you are you can take them out
you're ready to go before i head out to
fly
i want to show you guys the comparison
between the first mavic mini and the new
mavic air 2 that just recently came out
you guys got them right here mavic air 2
and mavic mini
1.
where where did you go mavic mini 1
controller
mavic mini 2 controller obviously much
larger in size you're going to get a
much longer battery life with this
larger one i also like being able to
have the phone connected above the
controller
whereas before this folded out and it
was below this is a very similar
controller style to a lot of the drones
the dji has so here's the previous
battery charger i like they're able to
get the batteries out easier because
before
honestly
like i actually could i
i can't do it watch this easy
thank you
so they do look very similar this one
seems like it's a little bit thinner and
then i just have different color
propellers
the new one has usbc instead of micro
usb
that is good news next up mavic air 2.
this i would say is one of my favorite
drones
so far because it still is small it's
pretty compact shoots 4k
has very long battery life but this
little guy is even smaller
does have increased battery life and now
that this shoots 4k that's
pretty much a game changer this is the
drone that first introduced this new
controller style
so it is actually it's the same
controller
which is great news because i really
like the new controller but look at the
battery size
comparison the mini 2 will get you about
31 minutes of flight time which is kind
of mind-blowing to think of where dji
started and where we are today
and now we're like oh 31 minutes how
will i
ever survive they don't know we're going
to be very yet they don't know
we're going to big bear
bye see you there i didn't tell them
where we were going i don't think so
[Music]
other than being able to shoot in 4k the
biggest upgrade to this is the fact that
they're now using ocusync 2.0 in the
previous mavic mini
it used wi-fi so you could only fly up
to four kilometers but with this you can
fly up to 10
you can fly faster further higher and
the battery life has been improved by
one minute and you know what one minute
is one minute of flight time that you
didn't have previously you're able to
change the led light on the front so
obviously
i changed it to pink i'm just excited to
be able to shoot in 4k
and they were able to squeeze that all
into still a weight of 249 grams
it's so light so light let's fly
[Music]
so right now i'm gonna test out the zoom
so there's a little button that says one
x when i click one x
this allows me to zoom in that now takes
you into 2x and i'm gonna fly with the
zoom on and see what that looks like
[Music]
um
one of my favorite things about dji is
obviously the software and i love being
able to take the quick shots you
basically push a button
and it flies for you and will get you a
really cool shot that you can instantly
post to social media
or just look at it on your phone and
enjoy it for your own
personal benefit the four quick shots
that you can do on here is the droney
the helix the rocket and the circle so
here's what all four of those look like
look at this little microphone i'm
shooting this on the pocket too it's so
[Music]
cool
pretty much
[Music]
is
love the mavic mini 2 and i'm really
excited for people to actually get a
chance to try this out this is a drone
that is kind of geared towards beginners
because it does use the dji fly app
which is a more simplified version
of the app that is used in their higher
end drones but it's so great because
this is 4k
even if you aren't a beginner drone
flyer this is so amazing because of the
size you could just throw in your bag
and basically always have it with you
and now that it shoots 4k the video
quality is so much better compared to
the previous version
that i cannot wait to take this with me
places that i normally wouldn't be able
to take a drone because of the size
i do wish the controller was a little
bit smaller but now that it is the
ocusync 2.0 you're going to have an
improved video transmission you're going
to be able to fly further faster longer
so i think that this is a very
significant upgrade one of the things
that i said in my original mavic mini
review is that i wish that this was 4k
and now our wishes have been granted so
i look forward to you guys checking this
out i'll put a link in the description
if you want to check out more
information
and again don't forget to subscribe and
i will see you in my next video
i love this little microphone
you